[Musique]
les shadoks ont pendu deux grandes
quantités 2 en arrivant sur la terre ils
attendent patiemment qu'ils aient clause
pour partir conquérir la planète mais
qu'il y avait un inconvénient c'est que
les shadoks vous le savez pour des deux
français il avait trouvé ça astucieux
étant donné que comme vous avez de trois
longues potes les oeuvres ordinaire ce
cas c'est à côté du mot faire évidemment
c'était pratique mais d'un autre côté
pas tellement car non seulement il ne se
passait pas mais il ne se casser pas il
ne se cassait pas du tout si bien que
quand le c'était mieux apprécier
le shadow qui tu es dedans on ne pouvait
pas surpris il fallait avoir une clé
leurs clés à eux c'est abe sylla l'avait
oublié chez eux
cdt spectacle vraiment affligeant de
voir ses poubelles qui pendant des
générations et des générations et des
données tant de mal pour réussir à
pondre des oeufs à gaza blessant donner
maintenant 1000 points peuvent pour
essayer de les casser
c'est pour ça que c'est pitié les et
naturellement nous cassez pas mais le
plus grand malheureusement il faut
l'avouer c'était le chat d'oc à
l'intérieur puis se casser
alors on lui de couver leurs oeufs
normalement comme vous l'auriez fait
vous et moi les shadoks les mettait à
rouiller et ça prenait sa prenez pas mal
de temps et souvent le shadow qui était
déjà prévu quand il sortait et ça
m'avait vraiment plus la peine
[Musique]